late night in Liverpool for some women
it's time to go to work hey guys but
it's dangerous work they face the risk
of rape abuse and violence how come for
them would you be about reporting to the
police report it yeah okay I promised on
it I'd be confident I'll tell them out
from the unknowing still remain when the
day when it's happen again the won't
happen to any of the girls Louise spends
the night patrolling the city offering
support to sex workers handing out
condoms and checking on their safety
agent pull over on the left here we have
a girl here busy one how long you been
here young boy ever dated here to frog
mrs. okay it's safer here though happy
everyday nokia me in this part of the
country the police have tried to build
relationships with sex workers now new
national guidance emphasizes support
instead of criminalization it's illegal
to sell sex
so it's alarm use a bit of common sense
and a bit of discretion and be mindful
of the communities that they were can
even though their boss these communities
as well you know so being severe are
working around public areas and areas
where the public huge list of schools
and things like that it's past 1am at
Liverpool and it's cold and it's wet and
yet we've seen almost a dozen women out
here selling sex on the street and it's
clear from talking to them that they
face real and serious dangers but it's
also clear that fear of the police isn't
one of them it feels like prostitution
is tolerated here it's a long way from
these scenes in London in 2013 the new
guidance wants police that brothel raids
create mistrust it's a change of
direction welcomed by sex like that
Charlotte rose we're all vulnerable
because of what the government has been
doing to us penalizing us criminalizing
what we're doing you know rather than
allowing us the safety at work which we
should be entitled to like any other
human being we're not where we r deemed
is the lowest of the low and maybe an
indoor worker but I still faces just as
many dangers as somebody who does on the
streets the problem is there's people on
the streets are penalized more because
of bad laws one alarm the idea of
creating a safer environment is a
backwards step for some campaigners our
Lawson's really mixed messages about
prostitution and we end up with a
situation in which some police forces
operate so-called manage zones now this
is where prostitution on the street can
take place now the job of the police is
not to manage sexual exploitation it to
end it the legality of prostitution may
be a deeply polarizing issue but
wherever you stand the continuing demand
is undeniable half wash Sky News